vamos a analizar una secuencia corta de
adn las letras que utilizaré son las
abreviaturas de varias bases núcleo
típicas o también llamadas bases
nitrogenadas que conforman una secuencia
de adn por ejemplo supongamos que
tenemos un poco de timina timina
citosina guanina citosina timina adenina
timina timina y finalmente otra timina
esta es nuestra secuencia de adn pero
cuál sería la secuencia correspondiente
de rn en la que sería transcrita si se
acuerdan de esto por los vídeos
anteriores pausa en el vídeo y traten de
resolverlo bueno aquí la clave es que si
hablamos de pares de bases en el adn la
adenina se empareja con la timina y la
citosina se empareja con la guanina pero
si hablamos de esos pares en el rn
entonces en lugar de timina en el rn
aquí tenemos brasil así que en este caso
sí
el adn tenemos timina eso corresponde a
una adenina en el aire en adenina
guanina citosina guanina adenina y como
ésta es una hebra de rn aquí en lugar de
timina tenemos brasil y después adenina
adenina adenina en este proceso que
acabamos de hacer se conoce como
transcripción transcripción y en este
caso fue una transcripción del adn al rn
ahora si hablamos de todo el proceso en
el que toda esta información tiene un
efecto en el cuerpo el siguiente paso es
partir del rn y traducirlo a una
proteína eso lo podemos hacer como vimos
en vídeos anteriores es decir si
agrupamos tres bases se forma un codón
que lo que hace es codificar para un
aminoácido en particular para saber para
qué aminoácido se hace la codificación
podemos ver una tabla de código genético
encontrarán con diferentes tipos de
tablas pero esta es la más común
entonces vamos a ver en este caso
nuestra primera letra es a la segunda
también es a y la tercera es g entonces
la primera letra es a la segunda letra
es a así que nos encontramos en esta
celda y la tercera letra es g por lo
tanto traduce al aminoácido lisina que
se abrevia como l y s esto quiere decir
lisina pero también pudimos haberlo
obtenido de otro tipo de tabla puede que
se encuentren con una tabla circular que
se ve así de cualquier manera obtenemos
el mismo resultado el triplete
ag empezando desde el centro sería a a g
y eso codifica para lisina bien ahora
vamos con el siguiente codón si ustedes
se sienten emocionados como yo los
invito a que pause en el vídeo y
continúen traduciendo esto el siguiente
codón es
y entonces sé que a codificar a arginina
arginina y después tenemos o aaa y aaa
nos lleva a este pequeño punto negro
pero qué significa bueno esto significa
que termina el codón en algunas
ocasiones puede que aquí se encuentre
escrita la palabra fin así que este es
el fin y claro no hay un aminoácido que
se llame fin en realidad esto le indica
al proceso de codificación que se
detenga y recuerden que todo esto ocurre
dentro de un ribosoma así que este es el
final de la secuencia de aminoácidos o
también conocida como secuencia poli
peptídica
ahora hagamos algunas cosas interesantes
pensemos en algunas situaciones en las
que existen mutaciones y en algunas de
estas bases tal vez algo es insertado o
eliminado o incluso puede ser que algo
haya sido intercambiado empecemos con
algo conocido como mutación puntual
supongamos que ésta se es intercambiada
por una a si esto ocurre entonces en la
hebra de rn aquí ahora tendremos un
asilo y si esto es un asilo entonces
podemos ver que a aje sigue igual y
codifica para lisina pero el segundo
codón ahora es diferente ahora para
quien codifica bueno si buscamos c&a c&a
ahora codifica para leucina en lugar de
arginina entonces escribimos l
que es la abreviación de leucina esto es
algo muy común que ocurre en una
mutación de sustitución se cambia a un
aminoácido en particular pero muchas
veces puede ser mucho más significativo
por
ejemplo si está g se intercambia por una
a entonces estás en el rn ahora será u y
después qué es lo que pasa el primer
codón siga codificando para lisina pero
el segundo ahora es og a g
y esto indica el fin así que el proceso
de codificación actual se detendría lo
que sería un gran problema porque si
esta secuencia de adn o mejor dicho si
el poli péptido no mutado tuviera que
continuar y de pronto aquí se detiene
antes de que miles de otros cordones
puedan terminar eso afectaría
significativamente a la proteína para la
que se está codificando ahora otro tipo
de mutación que comúnmente tiene un
efecto significativo es la mutación con
desplazamiento del marco de lectura que
es donde algo que es insertado o
eliminado lo cambia todo por ejemplo en
lugar de que sustituyera ag que pasaría
así a fuera insertada aquí
bueno ahora nuestra secuencia se vería
así de tc después tenemos a y después
gct at&t entonces ésta era nuestra
secuencia original pero la a fue
insertada aquí esta vez no reemplazó a g
y por lo tanto cambia todo lo que
tenemos hacia la derecha como nos
quedaría ahora si transcribimos al arn
ahora nos quedaría a a je je je
ah ah ah ah ah en donde el primer codón
sigue codificando para lisina ya lo
hemos visto muchas veces pero que me
dicen del segundo codón bueno el segundo
codón ahora es use je je je
ahora nos lleva a hacer in tenemos un
aminoácido diferente aquí lo más
interesante es que no sólo cambia un
aminoácido sino que sigue ocurriendo
aquí podemos ver que tenemos
y ah ah nos lleva a la iso leucina
isoleucina que es muy diferente de lo
que teníamos antes porque ahora ya no
tenemos un codón que ponga fin a la
codificación así que una mutación con
desplazamiento del marco de lectura en
donde insertamos o eliminamos algo hace
que toda la cadena cambie y puede
provocar un impacto grave en lo que eso
transcribe y después codifica pero
afortunadamente para nosotros aunque
ocurran las mutaciones existen
mecanismos de corrección de pruebas en
los sistemas biológicos que hacen que
las mutaciones sean menos frecuentes de
lo que normalmente serían y muchas
personas todavía tratan de entender cómo
es que funcionan completamente los
mecanismos de corrección de pruebas otra
cosa para tomar en cuenta es que
generalmente asociamos una mutación a
algo malo y bueno muchas veces si es
malo porque lo que solía ser una
proteína funcional deja de serlo porque
se detuvo muy pronto la codificación
existe una mutación de desplazamiento
del marco de lectura se codifican cosas
completamente diferentes por eso es que
muchas veces puede ser algo muy malo
incluso muchas enfermedades son causadas
por extrañas mutaciones como esta pero
otras veces puede ser que la mutación no
sea un grave problema quizá algo fue
intercambiado y solo cambio uno de los
aminoácidos que al final no cambia la
habilidad de la proteína para hacer su
trabajo en ese caso no hay problema pero
de vez en cuando una mutación puede ser
algo bueno de hecho necesitamos que
ocurra la mutación para que exista
variación en una población y gracias a
la variación es que se da la selección
natural y la evolución si no existiera
la variación entonces no tendríamos las
diferentes cosas que se seleccionan de
los distintos medio ambientes y con el
tiempo no tendríamos un cambio gradual
espero que ahora puedan tener una mejor
idea sobre la transcripción y después la
traducción
escribir aquí ocurre la transcripción de
adn y arn y aquí se da la traducción
traducción del a rn a proteína aquí
podemos darnos una idea de cómo funciona
cómo usar estas tablas de código
genético pero también vimos el impacto
que una mutación puntual o una mutación
de desplazamiento del marco de lectura
puede tener en la proteína para la que
se codifica nos vemos en otro vídeo